في جزر فيساياس الواقعه وسط الفلبين التي
يقطنها 17 مليون نسمه كان السكان على موعد
مع اكبر كارثه في عام 2013 واحد اقوى
الاعاصير على مر العصور حدث مريب تسبب في
مقتل الالاف وشرد ودمر مصادر رزق الملايين
انه اعصار هايان المعروف محليا باولاندا
فماذا حدث
في الاول من نوفمبر وفيما ظن الناس ان
موسم الاعاصير قد انتهى تكونت عاصفه
استوائيه فوق المحيط الهادئ ثم بدات تتحرك
غربا باتجاه الساحل الفلبيني مع سرعه
تتصاعد تدريجيا حيث بلغت اكثر من 300
وسبعين كيلو مترا في الساعه مع وصولها
لجزيرتي وسمر في صبيحه الثامن من نوفمبر
ما جعلها تصنف كاعصار من الفئه الخامسه في
غضون ساعات قليله كانت قد هطلت امطار
غزيره تم تقديرها بنحو 280 ملليمترا مما
تسبب في حدوث فيضانات وانزلاقات طينيه
تركزت في وسط الفلبين كما طالت تاثيراتها
وفيتنام والصين
بفعل الرياح العاتيه تحطمت اشجار جوز
الهند التي هي مصدر رزق اساسي للسكان
وتطايرت اسقف المنازل والنوافذ والابواب
كما جرفت المياه الفائده الصخور والسيارات
وانتشرت في قلوب الاهالي منهم ما تسلق
جذوع الاشجار ومنهم من بحث عن قطعه خشب
تحمله وسط الفوضى فيما شوهدت الكثير من
قطاع الاثاث والاجهزه الكهربائيه
والممتلكات الخاصه على سطح المياه
لم يستطع الكثيرون النجاه سته
الافوا حتفهم فيما اعتبر الف اخرون في
عداد المفقودين
مع استمرار اعمال الاغاثه اكدت الحكومه
الفلبينيه ان اكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص قد
نزحوا وان اكثر من 16 مليونا قد تضرروا
فيما تم الابلاغ عن اضرار بمليون منزل
نصفهم كان قد دمر بالكامل
اثر الكارثه اصبح خمسه ملايين وتسعمائه
الف عامل بلا وظائف حيث تم تدمير مناطق
انتاج الارز والسكر الرئيسي والكثير من
محاصيل جوز الهند التي تمثل ما يقرب من
نصف الصادرات الزراعيه الفلبينيه في كارثه
اقتصاديه كبرى حيث قدرت الاضرار الاجماليه
بنحو خمسه مليارات
و800 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]